by the way rachel maddow just got a 30
million dollar deal can you pull that up
rachel maddow from msnbc
got a 30 million dollar deal
inside a massive msnbc dual pane mata to
work less 30 million dollar annually
while ending her show next year and
giving their top star a more flexible
schedule than ever before
aggressive dream right there 30 million
management rachel maddow the capitalist
makes 30.
you send me the text you send me does
kai have that it should be it's in the
it's
show the ratings the different stats if
you got that pull that up to talk about
who's doing what that is crazy
she got a 30 million 30 million yeah and
you should see the views by the way like
how many views
they're getting versus others for her to
get a dirty 30 million dollar contract
so how often do you listen to her from
each their capacity to what's their
necessity no but do you ever listen to
her hi dan and by day with rachel maddow
you don't i uh i don't listen to her
that often but i i i'll like i do i only
do youtube now that's all i do i haven't
had a tv in two years times are tough
right to cut the court and save that
money
but since i moved to dallas and i lived
in that uh beautiful apartment you
recommended i've only watched youtube so
i watch a lot of clips
whether it's tucker whether it's rachel
maddow who's that beauty is that the
cupboard
i don't get that i don't get that cnn
spent nearly 80 of september
under 1 million viewers seriously
liberal network saw a 41 drop from
september 2020
uh
new cycle and that's with the new cycle
has hardly
president joe biden took office but cnn
doesn't appear to be reaping a benefit
cnn has a dismal september fallen nearly
1 million viewers on any of its program
of its programs for 23 out of 30 days in
a month equating two staggering 77 last
september the final weeks of 2020
elections cnn averaged 950 000
total day viewers this september network
average 557 primetime viewership has
virtually cut in half during the same
time from 1.5 million to 770 000 but but
show the one that gerard has show the
one that gerrard has can we see the most
watched programs or that's the one i
want the one that was
the comparative analysis do you have it
if you have that pull that up but you
were saying you listened to rachel
maddow everything no i don't i don't
i'll watch clips and she's certainly the
um
the front runner over at msnbc it's not
so what's their lineup that um you got
joy reid rachel madden now joey's not it
out at night is she well they have they
have lawrence o'donnell right after her
they've got brian williams i really like
brian williams before her they got um
uh i like brian williams chris chris
hayes all right so check this out
before christine hang on to joe reed and
roland sorrell again joined cnn's entire
primetime lineup in a fallen falling
below the humiliating line of 1 million
total viewers joy has fewer viewers than
the shows before and after her don lemon
and anderson cooper barely getting 500
i thought anderson cooper almost no no
no viewers under 55.
click on it click on it to see it
so uh four o'clock cavuto 1.7 million
tapper 731 wallace one point two six six
you've got alcohol
five is the number one show out of
everybody five's hilarious it
the old pro wrestler is i do love them
2.8 five seven five is the number one
show five p.m
then it's tapper again 6 46.
uh
1.963
blitzer
is at what
you see it at 6 pm that's the new star
on msnbc that's ari melber he's he's
pretty corny and he tries to rap
sometimes
he's not bad he's a he's a smart
attorney
prime time 1.87 burnett 602 reid
979 carlson 2.601 the 5 is beating
carlson
cooper 638 hayes 1.214 that's chris
right 1.214
and then you got hannity 2.343
cooper 570
uh what's that one trms the rachel
maddow the rachel maddow show okay
uh
and then you got the ingram 1.1915
lemon 528 so who's the low side amongst
everybody here
he is the lowest amongst everybody
here's actually what you have to do
because obviously on the on this
three
headed monster you have fox news as the
only thing right of center wait wait
stay on that stay
and then you have cnn left of center and
then you have arguably msnbc
left of cnn so you know what i would say
today so i'm just saying you have to com
like they're eating into each other's
market shares so
bear is still beating those two combined
yes reed and burnett is losing to prime
time hayes and cooper is getting
destroyed by carlson uh rachel maddow
and cooper are getting destroyed by
hannity last word and lamont are still
losing to ingram williams and lemon the
only person the only one that's beating
the other side
is tapper and wallace combined
yeah so if you combine the two yeah so
even so if you say there's the top three
political shows msnbc cnn fox fox
single-handedly is still beating the
other guys if you think about it so what
does that mean in the big picture of
things
i think there still means 46 percent are
going to vote republican 40 no 44
percent is going to do republican for 42
is going to do republican 44 is going to
do demik whatever the number is 12 in
the middle three is going to do this i
think you're really dealing with 10 or
12 percent nothing's changed i disagree
with that completely i think that what
this tells you is that the future is
completely and totally up for grabs i
think this i i agree with that i agree
with that it's because there's nobody
now how many i would love to know what
the average person at nine o'clock
is doing as far as age yeah is doing
under 25 years old yeah what are they
watching how are they watching if anyone
under 35 years old is watching any of
this yeah any of this because if you're
if you're 18 to 30 you're watching
youtube you're not even on this crap
tick tock youtube listen
you gotta realize all those numbers are
great rogan destroys them yep russell
brand destroys them i mean you can go so
many different shows that are podcasts
that are doing stuff that are killing
these guys but rachel maddow makes 30 a
year okay
30 30 year and what does rogan do rogan
gets a 100 million contract with uh
spotify with uh spotify i had a uh
i had a video on tick tock get two
million views uh yesterday and i get
taken down today
well that seems to be pretty normal for
you why are you surprised that your
stuff gets taken down at this point
you're just seriously glad i'm just
happy you got two million views
yeah yeah
you got you got the s m thing going on
see you later buddy so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]